como en una película de terror a las 4
de la mañana los habitantes de la favela
vila cruzeiro en río de janeiro se
despertaron con el sonido de un tiroteo
en un bosque pegado al asentamiento
fruto de un operativo policial en el que
buscaban a narcotraficantes que
supuestamente se escondían en la favela
del norte de la ciudad y que se saldó
con la vida de varios residentes
no creo que podamos normalizar que el
estado entre en una favela y deje 20
cadáveres o más no sabemos por qué
todavía tenemos que recuperar cuerpos
del bosque
hace poco más de tres meses en febrero
la policía ya mató a ocho personas
presuntamente involucradas en acciones
ilegales en vila cruzeiro y es que en
los cientos de favelas de río de janeiro
estas redadas son habituales y muchos
han tenido que enterrar a sus seres
queridos
no hay una justicia honesta y
lamentablemente los que sufrimos somos
nosotros la población de este suceso se
produce un año después de la mayor
matanza policial de río en la favela
jacarezinho que se saldó con la vida de
28 personas desde entonces sólo dos
policías han sido procesados y diez de
las tres de investigaciones sobre abuso
policial han sido archivadas allí la
gente todavía vive con miedo
fue zetas
la policía se creó para que nos
sintiéramos seguros pero lo que sentimos
es miedo porque cuando escuché la voz
dentro de la casa sentimos miedo
entramos en pánico porque escuchamos los
disparos los gritos como invadían las
casas
estaba escrito
en su memoria en los vecinos del barrio
levantaron un muro azul con el nombre de
las víctimas pero la policía que a
partir de junio de 2020 ya no puede
llevar a cabo redadas sin informar al
ministerio público lo derribo por
supuesta apología al tráfico de drogas